qui qu'est-ce que nous dit cette absence
cette discrétion est-ce que des purges
ont été menées au sein des rangs de
l'armée par Poutine
macabre on rappelle que depuis le 24
février 2022 une quinzaine de ligaques
d'industriels soit sont tombés par le
balcon sont été victimes d'une crise
cardiaque bref des gens qui apparemment
étaient en très mauvaise santé peut-être
que c'est la richesse et l'opulence qui
causait cette fragilité bon oui il faut
se poser les questions parce que vous
savez les purges je dirais c'est une
tradition en Russie ça n'est pas parce
que c'est la Russie il y a d'autres pays
quand on a connu l'otsarisme le
communisme et le putinisme on en sait un
rayon sur les purges alors on a bien vu
qu'il y avait déjà quelqu'un qui avait
perdu son costume militaire c'était ses
vieilles choses ou le ministre de la
Défense bon il l'a retrouvé mais c'est
vrai que quand vous le voyez apparaître
en costume suivi alors qu'il ne l'est
jamais en tout cas face aux caméras
c'est une première c'est un premier
indice ça veut dire que c'est un
renoncement assez fonctions non ça veut
dire que probablement on lui inflige une
forme de brimade à moins qu'il soit je
parle sans sans présager de ce que
demain peut-être mais sans préjugés de
ce que demain peut-être mais on lui
infime inflige une sorte de brimade oui
de brimade en disant
tu as pas été forcément au bon endroit
au bon moment tu as pas pris les bonnes
décisions donc attention à toi et demain
présente-toi avec un costume civil et tu
retrouveras après vous savez c'est
une humiliation c'est infantile c'est
profondément péril et ça correspond au
à la paranoïa de Vladimir Poutine donc
premier point deuxième point vous avez
le fait que l'argumentaire de Poutine
tourne autour de la corruption et de
donc de mauvais on a parlé de
polygologie et de sa société la
corruption les mauvais les mauvais
de la de la patrie russe le fait que
tout ça tourne autour de ce contre quoi
les Russes sont vents debout la plupart
du temps c'est important et puis vous
avez le fait aussi tout simplement que
la comment dirais-je la posture d'un
Poutine face à ça et d'attaquer tout
azimut et probablement parce qu'il ne
sait pas quel est le degré de
moisissure de planches voisines dans son
armée on sait très bien que dans
d'autres punch l'armée c'est presque
scindé en deux parties il y avait un
célèbre régiment qui emmène 993 de
régiment étoilé avec une gloire
fantastique et bien certains sont allés
pour soutenir les conservateurs de
l'époque qui sont les ancêtres
idéologiques de Poutine et d'autres
s'étrangés du côté DLC et donc vous
voyez la prévision j'en terminerai là la
prévision sur ce qui va se passer est
extrêmement difficile à faire parce que
une évolution de ce type là dans un
régime dictatorial ça peut dépendre
d'une petite bascule d'une fraction
de soit de l'armée soit des services
soit des renseignements militaires qui à
un moment donné donneront leurs faveur à
un camp ou un autre et ça ça n'est pas
forcément prévisible à l'avance la
preuve c'est que brigogine lui pensait
bien avoir cette bascule en sa faveur et
qu'il ne l'a pas eu contrairement à ses
attentes et même peut-être parce qu'on
l'avait promis ou garantie on a quelques
secondes mais cette ce commandement
fragilisé ça va forcément avoir des
répercussions sur le terrain d'un mot
d'un mot ça veut dire que dans l'esprit
Poutine et vous le voyez bien il est
prêt à s'aborer un certain nombre de
choses qui sont pourtant capitale pour
lui pour poursuivre ce qu'est son
obsession c'est pareil avec l'Ukraine
face même aux problèmes de l'armée et de
la désindustrialisation russe il
continue c'est le primat de l'île
idéologies et c'est ce qui caractérise
les régies autoritaires merci beaucoup
Gauthier merci pour cette